over fifty percent of Europeans
regularly make purchases online but how
are their consumer rights protected and
how is the market regulated em eps have
updated a director from 2007 with the
aim of keeping up with the rapid
technological advances in the sector I
premium mercato al Tracy Nov operatory
reduce amo y cosas de un sistema drop
off ramen tato a car yes quick oh Stoke
impressive 00 g amanta at silk acento
trenta Millie rd de Oro lon everyone is
familiar with paypal but how many people
knew trust Lee or so forth the swedish
and german counterparts of the American
online payments giant the new rules are
meant to help new payment providers
emerge and push them to be innovative
you've managed to break open a little
bit the market that is good for the
economy it's good for innovation it's
good for e-commerce another aspect mep s
have considered is security for
consumers especially data protection and
text chaffee progressively duarte
consommateurs on shalini on Sora
directive protección de donde y la serda
in precum protección de donde person
area the new rules should now be
approved by all 28 member states coming
into force as soon as possible after
that
you